euh par hasard un Guadeloupe je voilà je
travaillais là-bas je vivais là-bas vous
faisiez quoi là-bas sécurité et donc le
patron pour lequel je travaillais avait
organisé encore le concert en Guadeloupe
à l'époque en 99 et il m'avait désigné
chauffeur chauffeur de Johnny donc là
vous allez chercher je vais le chercher
et ça se passe pas mal pas mal mais
c'est voilà vous êtes content de le voir
vous étiez un peu Fan avant ou pas du
tout non pas du tout
d'accord vous allez chercher une idée
comme si vous allez chercher le mot ou
quoi c'est à peu près ça mais donc on
l'aurait fait tout aussi bien ah oui bah
bravo bravo c'est tout à votre honneur
non non mais et donc là Johnny dans la
dans la voiture il est tout seul ou pas
non Laetitia d'accord Laetitia et son
responsable sécurité d'accord et donc là
tout se passe bien ça se passe bien le
petit séjour à Guadeloupe se passe bien
donc du coup
il demande à ce que je suis en
Martinique d'accord ce que je fais et
puis voilà et pour moi l'histoire
s'arrête là d'accord donc normalement
pour vous derrière vous dites quoi vos
potes vous dites avec Johnny il était
super ou bien voilà
très cool très cool mais vous dites pas
où vous attendez pas ce que elle revoit
ah non pas du tout pas du tout alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe après parce que
c'est vrai que qu'est-ce qui se passe
donc là vous il repart forcément il
rentre et moi je rentre non non par
contre j'avais changé le numéro avec le
responsable sécurité des productions
carbu d'accord voilà et donc quand je
suis rentré donc en métropole donc à
Paris donc j'avais recontacté on s'était
on avait communiqué avec Monsieur rifas
d'accord et
donc là un jour il m'a rappelé pour me
dire écoute va te présenter il cherche
quelqu'un
voilà je suis allé vous êtes allé où
chez Monsieur
[Musique]
d'accord donc c'est dans le 16e
arrondissement de Paris et ça donc
puis j'ai dû commencer 48 heures après
donc quand vous arrivez et vous
reconnaît il vous dit ouais alors oui il
me reconnait parce qu'il y a quoi il y a
deux mois à peine de ça que on s'était
croisé en Guadeloupe voilà et puis bon
voilà il savait que j'avais déjà
rencontré donc du coup voilà il est pas
surpris de me voir ça a été rapide
l'entretien d'embauche avec Johnny
qu'est-ce que vous a dit
que
je te promets non
j'ai pas dit quand vos cheveux c'est
talent comme un cheval
et donc très vite vous dites ça y est je
suis embauché par Johnny
il vous dit quoi vous démarrez quand
vous dites je démarre 48 heures après
mais pas avec lui en fait au début je
démarre avec Laetitia parce que lui est
tourné il a déjà donc quelqu'un avec lui
et je suis principalement avec Laetitia
donc je commence en juin 99 et jusqu'au
mois de
[Musique]
août voilà je suis essentiellement avec
Laetitia et quelquefois lui
effectivement quand il fait des retours
de tournée à Paris voilà d'accord alors
et pour moi ça s'arrête là je pense
honnêtement que
voilà comment comment vous avez basculé
après de Laetitia Johnny
ah mais c'était prévu pour les c'était
prévu pour pour lui mais pour en fait en
gros c'était la période d'essai quoi je
l'ai prise comme ça moi il a été content
de vous Laetitia aussi était content de
vous visiblement tente de vous donc elle
vous a dit allez tout va bien voilà
alors de titre livre c'est tout le monde
l'appelait Johnny ou la police
parce que vous avez fait ensemble
célèbre Paris Dakar je crois que Johnny
à l'époque vous rappelez du Paris Dakar
mais c'est quoi votre meilleur souvenir
je dirais que c'est le Paris de la
carrosserie ah vraiment on va voir les
images
on fait la fermeture des boîtes de nuit
à Saint-Tropez ou à Paris bref c'était
pas la joie morceau choisi
le poignet dans dans les dunes c'est le
volant c'est ce que tu veux on a cassé
encore un truc je l'ai retrouvé plus la
route
Johnny Hallyday René mais ils ont perdu
8 heures sur le vainqueur de l'étape
c'est beaucoup mais c'est sans doute le
prix à payer pour celui qui ne veut pas
se priver de désert
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes avec lui
oui et puis surtout c'est que
on avait entendu après que oui qu'on
disait pas non non
et puis voilà c'est oui effectivement
quand on fait une voiture comme ça ouais
ça rapproche oui c'est quoi votre pire
souvenir avec Johnny Hallyday
l'hôpital à Los Angeles
et que je le vois la première fois en
réanimation c'est violent voilà
et ça fait ça fait ça fait quelque chose
classique pour Johnny Hallyday
vous alliez le chercher à quelle heure
du nez
lui honnêtement et c'était pas quand
même quelqu'un du matin donc on va dire
que c'était en fin de matinée
mais alors après avec au bout de
quelques mois
surtout de à partir du moment où vous en
déménagé donc après à marne-la-coquette
j'avais possibilité d'arriver un peu
plus tôt d'utiliser la salle de sport en
bas c'était donc j'arrivais un peu plus
tôt comme ça que j'étais sur place
[Musique]
12 ans au quotidien plus 4 ans après de
tourner voilà sur 12 ans c'est énorme
vous êtes déjà m'embrouillés un jour
vous dites une fois une fois on a eu
voilà un petit échange un peu plus tendu
voilà mais
ça c'est ça c'est fait sur quoi
il me reprochait d'être pas suffisamment
aimable avec les amis
alors c'était vrai en plus pour
probablement pourquoi vous restiez dans
votre parce que il y avait certains amis
qui déblateraient dans son dos et que
moi je savais donc du coup ça me
plaisait pas beaucoup ça c'est fort ça
c'est bien donc et donc et donc lui
avait dit ça Johnny
ils m'ont envoyé peut-être boulet je
sais pas non je me suis pas permis de le
dire voilà mais donc du coup j'ai
forcément un peu compliqué
vous êtes dit ouais je sais qu'il parle
mal de Johnny dans son dos donc je vais
j'ai pas envie d'être sympa avec eux
après moi j'ai appris à l'être quand
même vous êtes forcé voilà il faut jouer
le jeu mais c'est vrai quoi Johnny vous
a dit ouais il faut que tu sois un peu
plus cool avec mes peurs vous êtes pas
tendre avec ses amis dans le livre vous
dites que beaucoup vivaient assez
crochet vous avez en fait une relation
avec lui pour le pour le business pour
des intérêts et que quand ils se
baladait personne sauf quelques rares
exceptions on payait jamais et que
Johnny dépensait tout quoi c'est exact
vous êtes assez critique envers les amis
non je dis ce que je constaté ce que
j'ai vu c'est oui on s'est peut-être une
critique mais c'est juste ce que j'ai vu
constater vécu parce que très
honnêtement on a depuis son décès on a
vu beaucoup de choses beaucoup de gens
vont parler beaucoup de gens ont écrit
mais personne ne vivait avec
moi je quasiment je vivais avec
moi pour dormir puis point et donc c'est
pour ça que je me suis permis
effectivement de remettre quelques
petits trucs effectivement oui
voilà je dis que j'avais peu de gens qui
sortaient la carte bleue pour régler une
addition bah c'est ça voilà
c'est une constatation simplement vous
travaillez vous étiez 7 jours sur 7 avec
lui
parfois oui c'est ça
vous êtes déjà embrouillés pour lui
enfin il y a eu une bagarre voilà à
cause de lui ou un truc comme ça ouais
une autre fois oui pourquoi une fois
c'était ouais en boîte de nuit ouais
j'ai
monsieur qui était passablement
alcoolisé qui voulait s'en prendre pour
c'est pas pourquoi ça fait Louis
j'ai pas demandé son prénom
et l'autre fois
une autre une autre fois c'est parce que
lui voulait régler un petit problème
avec des fans et donc c'est moi qui m'a
suivi occupé
mais on était suivi en permanence par
une équipe de fans et donc lui a
descendu de un feu rouge et descendu
pour aller s'expliquer avec donc du coup
c'est moi qui suis allé
et puis en parlant des fans vous avez
déjà été face à des fans complètement
ouf de Johnny parce que je sais qu'il y
a des trucs dans le livre incroyable
vous dites Johnny respecter ses fans
mais je me méfiais de le mot fan est un
dérivé de fanatique pour ceux de Johnny
le terme non négligeable voué à
l'artiste une quasi vénération Johnny
avait des fans dans les sentiments à son
égard d'espacé de largement le cadre de
la plein d'un simple admiration
enlever de la psychiatrie vous dites
pour pour un ou deux cas oui il y avait
quoi comme truc de fou avec des fans il
y a eu un personnage à annonlé quand on
tournait le film L'Homme du train qui
donc est j'ai appris appris
qu'effectivement il avait un
psychiatrique par les gendarmes qui sont
venus me voir et
qui est arrivé dans notre dos en fait je
j'ignore quelles étaient ses intention
réelle en fait
mais donc j'ai dû le bloquer
très très fermement pour
pour le pas qu'il approche et le
lendemain effectivement j'ai appris que
ce personnage avait eu des soucis et qui
effectivement est relevé de la
psychiatrie donc il faudrait peut être
dangereux pour Johnny
et j'ai pas laissé le temps que vous
avez pas vous cacher de faire quoi que
ce soit alors
on est exclusivité un Patric Roussel
celui qui a travaillé avec Johnny 17 ans
est avec nous ce soir et c'est vrai que
voilà il y a des révélations dans le
livre incroyable vous dites il y avait
des tatouages il y a même vous avez même
notamment croisé une femme qui s'est
fait tatouer Johnny Hallyday sur les
seins
en 2016 votre contrat s'est arrêté
pourquoi il s'est arrêté le contrat il y
a eu une rupture en deux temps alors
juste avant parce que j'avais une petite
anecdote c'est que il y avait Johnny
Hallyday qui lui a demandé ce que son
mari en pensait de cette femme qui a eu
marqué Johnny Hallyday c'est vrai que
vous avez fait votre femme
pour certaines personnes tout le monde
l'artiste passait avant leur conjoint
justement
parce que on parle de ça c'est vrai que
vous vous savez tous les secrets de
Johnny bah oui est-ce que vous mentiez à
Laetitia de demander est-ce que vous
montiez Laetitia parfois
elle vous posez des questions Laetitia
genre il était où hier soir
non non jamais non vous vous répondiez
pas de toute façon non vous disiez pas
parce qu'à un moment ou quoi il y a
quand même un moment où vous êtes en
Suisse
il y a des prostituées qui viennent vous
vous refusez d'aller avec une prostituée
et ça vous n'en parlez pas à Laetitia là
c'est un accord entre vous ça se passe
en Suisse entre nous elle est pas là
donc il y avait beaucoup de choses que
Laetitia ne savait pas quand même j'ai
pas menti j'ai au milieu non mais il y a
beaucoup de choses qui n'étaient pas
révélées à Laetitia de la vie de Johnny
et donc
mon boulot je le dis oui
ce qui vous disait parfois si les 17
demande un truc tu réponds rien ou un
truc comme ça
oui c'est peut-être arrivé une ou deux
fois mais non en fait il y avait pas
besoin de dire quoi que ce soit mais mes
notes mais ils sont restés la même chose
dans l'autre sens
sur les amis sur le couple c'est
compliqué mais non vous saviez tout
ouais
effectivement et c'est pour ça que je
dis dans le livre ce qui doit rester
secret restera secret kamela justement
votre contrat s'est arrêté en 2016
pourquoi il s'est arrêté le contrat
j'ai démissionné
en 2011 fin 2011 pourquoi et parce que
les conditions qui m'était proposées
pour travailler à Los Angeles de me
convenait plus combien c'était payé
je me rappelle plus à peu près
le salaire n'était pas aussi conséquent
que ça il y avait des avantages naturels
mais pour Los Angeles il a acheté une
maison pour que je vive le Los Angeles
ou pas parce que c'est vous étiez
chauffeur et sécurité vous vous êtes
rentré chez moi avec la voiture j'avais
la voiture le voilà mais
on vous citez mon petit thé un peu
Patrick mais c'est vrai que c'est aussi
c'est intéressant on a toujours envie de
savoir combien on gagne si on est malade
numéro 1 de la sécurité de Johnny
on aurait pu probablement ce que s'il
avait souhaité s'il avait fait la
demande auprès de des ministères
compétents probablement que j'aurais pu
l'être à une époque il m'en a parlé je
le dis dans le livre justement il m'en a
parlé je suis pas fan donc j'ai noyé le
poisson et j'ai fait un intermédiaire
j'avais remettais procuré donc très
légalement un pistolet gum gum voilà qui
car les balles en caoutchouc et ça a
fait l'affaire pendant quelques temps et
puis après le truc je l'ai rangé il
était menacé à une époque non pour être
armée Johnny
je sais pas cette idée j'en sais rien
mais on dirait votre contrat s'est
arrêté en 2016 et en premier arrêt en
2011 pourquoi les conditions alors voilà
parce que il fallait donc que je crée ma
société donc à Los Angeles aux
États-Unis et que je facture l'artiste
tous les mois
donc ça me faisait perdre quand même
tous mes avantages sociaux que j'avais
donc en Suisse puisque donc à ce
moment-là j'étais résidentialiste parce
que j'avais déjà suivi en Suisse et non
j'ai dit non non
de vous garder en salariés c'est ça non
non
j'ai demandé à être licencié d'accord en
2011 et ensuite j'ai continué par
l'intermédiaire par le biais d'une
société suisse a travaillé que sur les
tournées voilà et là en 2016 il s'est
passé
[Musique]
non parce que peut-être que c'est mal
compris mais à propos dans le livre
aussi moi je dis qu'elle a écarté tout
le monde et elle a pu prendre ça aussi
pour un pu prendre ça pour une attaque
effectivement mais moi je ne fais que
relater des faits ce que j'ai vu et
constater point c'est moi c'est ma
vérité et après mais combien de femmes
prennent font ça effectivement mais dans
tous les cas dans le livre je ne juge
pas je dis l'effet et je ne juge pas je
dis pas si c'était bien ou mal je dis
juste voilà l'effet Patrick est-ce que
vous avez assisté à des forcément il y a
des altercations des voilà il y a des
des voilà des disputes est-ce que vous
qu'est-ce que vous faisiez dans ces
cas-là
ça ça fait partie de la phrase ce qui
doit rester secret d'accord donc il y a
eu des voilà c'est c'est ça oui vous
dites que Johnny est un justiciable
comme les autres mais qu'il avait des
passes droites quand même parfois oui
quand même un petit peu c'est normal
ils nous arrivait de rouler un peu vite
voilà on s'est fait arrêter quelques
fois par les policiers on repartait avec
un autographe
on s'en doute c'est normal vous l'aimiez
ou pas
mais vous avez vous avez vraiment un
amour pour Lui vous aviez une amitié
pour lui
un profond respect pour son respect vous
étiez pas si proche que ça j'ai
l'impression si on était proche mais
j'ai toujours voulu quand même garder
une licence patron employée mais ce qui
est incroyable c'est que vous n'avez
après 17 années passées ensemble vous
n'êtes pas invité à l'enterrement
comment ça se fait
parce que j'ai ils ont pas d'y penser
les proches n'ont pas dû penser ailleurs
problème ça faisait quelques temps que
je t'ai sorti de du cadre donc du coup
15 ans 17 ans c'est qui c'est qui qui
vous a pas invité oui le nouvel
entourage le nouveau producteur les
avocats de Johnny que vous critiquez
beaucoup et puis Laetitia aussi il faut
le dire vous pensez que c'est elle qui
vous je pense honnêtement que quand on
perd son mari et que
on entre d'autres chats fouetter voilà
il y a d'autres personnes qui sont
chargées de d'organiser et de c'est plus
à cela peut-être que j'en voudrais
qu'un nom ça franchement non il y avait
d'autres trucs à faire vous aurez voulu
être à l'enterrement de Johnny oui parce
que après ce qu'on a partagé avec ce
qu'on a fait ensemble voilà j'aurais
juste voulu lui rendre un dernier roman
j'effectivement 12 ans c'est un truc de
fou moi tous les jours
les premières années oui quasiment et
après ouais on va dire 330 jours par an
alors vous dites dans le livre vous
racontez que Laetitia empêchait Johnny
de voir sa fille Laura non c'est pas ça
que je dis j'ai cependant eu beaucoup de
mal à comprendre et admettre qu'il ne
puisse rencontrer sa propre fille qu'en
cachette
et je dis que elle ne devait pas savoir
c'est pas la même chose voilà quand il
voyait sa fille effectivement Laetitia
ne devait pas être au courant au début
après ça c'est un peu à m'arranger un
petit peu voilà
c'est
voilà il me demandait oui effectivement
de tenir dans mon portable pour ne pas
que elle appelle avec qui vous entendiez
mieux dans l'entourage de Johnny
j'ai l'impression que c'était la folie
non je sais pas j'aurais du mal j'aurais
du mal à définir quelqu'un et vous avez
des rapports ou des relations avec David
avec Laura avec les ongles depuis le
décès non non vous avez des rapports
avec personne en depuis le dessus non je
parle avec la famille de Johnny enfin
dans la vie de tous les jours parce que
vous voulez
complètement depuis le décès c'est
terminé j'ai plus de contact du tout
pourquoi vous avez voulu écrire ce livre
Patrick
un parti parce que alors pour rétablir
certaines choses parce que j'ai entendu
des choses beaucoup de choses et ça m'a
voilà ça m'a un peu agacé donc je
voulais juste moi raconter ma vérité
parce que moi j'étais dedans en fait il
y a beaucoup de gens qui l'ont qui ont
parlé beaucoup qui ont dit des choses
mais c'était en dehors où ils étaient là
par moments et puis après il partait
où exagéré des fois des amis qui étaient
amitiés mais pas aussi voilà il se
voyait pas tous les jours
ensemble et
aussi pour
mes enfants parce que je le dis dans le
livre ça a été compliqué avec mes
enfants parce que donc j'avais des
enfants et que les voyaient pas donc
du coup
je voulais
quelque part qui sont un petit peu de
fiers de moi tout simplement et
il y a quelques mois de ça et j'ai une
fille qui est assez grande mais elle m'a
dit mais bon j'ose pas dire ce que tu
faisais avant parce qu'en fait on me
croit pas
en fait il y en a tellement j'ai pas été
le seul à faire ce boulot là pour lui
attention il y en a eu avant il y a bien
sûr
mais et donc du coup il y en a tellement
qui ont dit qu'ils ont fait ce boulot là
et donc je dis pas je parce que les gens
me croient pas
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous diriez
à Johnny c'est quoi la dernière chose
que vous avez dit à Johnny
c'était un tourné c'était le dernier
concert en juin je pense
2016 avant avant les concerts à Nouméa
et voilà c'était là le dernier concert
vous l'avez pas dit
non
j'aimerais juste te dire que si ça s'est
arrêté c'est pas moi qui choisit c'est
pas c'est pas dans mon fait voilà